image à travers plusieurs extraits de
films je vous propose de revenir sur la
carrière exceptionnelle de lino ventura
sa première apparition sur les écrans
date de 1953 aux côtés de jean gabin qui
deviendra d'ailleurs son ami ce qui est
étonnant chez lino ventura c'est qu'en
dépit de son côté bourgault et bagarreur
il savait émouvoir le spectateur soit
pas cheap et bleu frais il est toujours
gérable
qu'est-ce qu'on a dû se faire piéger
pas dit ça
non je n'ai pas dit ça mais vous y
pensez
on a payé c'est normal
on va tout noble
sur la vie sur le métier en face un
vieux cheval
et pas qu'ils ont autre chose à faire
aujourd'hui les flics alors pas voulu
venir
j'ai téléphoné jeudi vient d'avoir voulu
même quand je serai mort tu me crois
même avoir à votre pièce
si ça c'est ma pièce qu'est ce qu'on
fait vous serrez du un nom prénom
profession martineau mais déjà demandé
maintenant c'est moi qui vous le demande
reste molle et croûte à toutes les
demandes et toutes les réponses allant
j'attends des réponses vous appelez
martineau oui jérôme oui jérôme charlie
mille notaire 40 prend beaujard delattre
jour orange oui vous êtes mariés oui
sans en prendre aux enfants
pourquoi ça pose des saletés ya quelque
chose
bonjour